اهلا بك سيد انس
تقييمك لعمليات البحث والانقاذ حيث
تتواجدون بها الطاي
ات من سيدي صاحب الجلاله الملك عبد الله
الثاني بن الحسين المعظم ومن لحظه وقوع
الزلزال في تركيا وانباع عن وجود العديد
من الاصابات والوفيات توجه فريق البحث
والانقاذ الاردني الى تركيا لتقديم للراس
الانسانيه والبحث والتفتيش عن الاشخاص
المفقودين تحت الانقاذ طبعا توجهنا بكامل
طاقاتنا وبكامل امكانياتنا من مطار ماركه
العسكري بطائرات سلاح الجو الملكي الاردني
الى مطار اضنه ومن ثم الى منطقه هاتاي وتم
تحديد كوبا وبدانا العمل في منطقه هذا
طبعا عملنا بكافه امكانياتنا من خلال 104
من طاقم فريق البحث والانقاذ الاردني
المؤهلين التاهيل الاحترافي والمزودين
باحدث المعدات المتخصصه في عمليات البحث
والانقاذ ايضا شتى يوجد برفقاتنا خمس
اطباء من الخدمات الطبيه الملكيه لتقديم
الرعايه الطبيه في المناطق المنكوبه ومن
لحظه وصولنا للغايه هذه اللحظه ما
عملياتنا عمليات البحث والانقاذ مستمره
وبحمد الله هناك تعاون مستمر وتنسيق عالي
مع السلطات المحليه في المنطقه المنكوبه
خصوصا في المنطقه التي يعمل فيها الفريق
الاردني
الجهود كبيره يعني محفوظه بنوع ما
بالمخاطر ولكن ان شاء الله العمل
الاحترافي والدؤوب يعني نطلع من
المواقع بشكل سليم بدون ما يتضرر اي ناس
وان شاء الله نحاول نساعد اخواننا الاشقاء
في
الجمهوريه التركيه يعني بكل جهودنا لتقديم
يدلعون المساعده لهم على جميع المستويات
وعلى جميع مستويات جهود الاغاثه الانسانيه
بكافه انواع انس من خلال رؤيتك للواقع على
الارض هل هناك من فرص نجاه لاناس احياء
بعد اربعه ايام على هذا الزلزال المدمر
نعم نعم يعني
ان
متوقعين في اي لحظه يكون في ناس احياء
فنعمل باحترافيه عاليه لانه يعني الامل
موجود ولا ولا ينقطع
يعني انه يكون موجود ناس احياء تحت
الانقاذ يعني ان شاء الله انه عندما تكون
الجهود المبذوله يعني باخلاص وللانسانيه
وتفاني ان شاء الله انه بتكون الامور على
ما يرام شكرا جزيلا لك اذا المقدم انس
العبادي قائد فريق البحث والانقاذ الاردني
والدولي